something insane is happening right now
there's this thing called bitcoin
it has to be a giant scam right i mean
it's just worthless
internet money you're telling me that a
digital coin
named after an internet meme is now
worth more than ford
it's insane
[Music]
unless you've been living under a rock
you've no doubt heard about
bitcoin a completely virtual form of
currency controlled by
no government and no single individual
created by a mysterious founder
who remains anonymous to this day a
currency
that is now worth billions bitcoin the
digital currency created a dozen years
ago
as an alternative to cash is exploding
the fair case is that it's a giant
pyramid scheme
and uh people are getting sucked into it
first i'll point out that bitcoin
possesses
all the attributes not only of good
money but of supremely good money
you probably have your own opinion on
the subject whether it's confusion
anger hope this bitcoin seems to stir up
controversy and polarization wherever it
goes
why it's about time that we unveil the
curtains and find out exactly
what is going on behind all the noise
and why bitcoin has stirred up the
reaction that it has
because at the heart of it all is
something much bigger than just
a digital coin and it's important that
you understand it
it's time that we place bitcoin on trial
[Music]
there's a temptation when you're first
presented with bitcoin
a temptation to mock and finally new
rule
nothing with crypto in the title ever
turns out good
you go to twitter and you see these
profiles with laser eyes in them the
memes the community the shouts of
huddle not to mention some of the
doomsday predictions of the us dollars
collapse and the end of fiat currency as
we know it
it's a lot our gut instinct
is to be cynical it's there's no value
it's a bubble and i
promise you and you're right it could go
to fifty thousand it could go to a
hundred thousand
but i i'm certain that the end of the
day it will end up close to zero
how could a virtual currency something
that was once literally labeled
magic internet money be worth so much
where is the intrinsic value that this
thing provides to the world
that's the first question that everyone
almost always
asks it's only when you're presented
with an understanding of the technology
and philosophy behind it all
that you realize you've been asking the
wrong question
all along we've covered some of this in
the first part of the series
but to recap bitcoin is simply a bunch
of transactions on a ledger that tell us
who sent what amount of bitcoins to who
in the same way a bank stores all the
transactions you've made from your
account
with a bank however each transaction is
validated by the bank themselves
if you try to send 100 to a friend when
you only have 50 dollars in your account
the bank will notice that this is an
invalid transaction
and reject it the bank is a central
authority
bitcoin's goal is to be a decentralized
form of currency
which satoshi nakamoto its mysterious
creator
outlined in their white paper published
during the 2008 recession
instead of relying on a bank to verify
that the transactions are legitimate
transactions are instead validated by a
bunch of computers that exist on the
bitcoin network
a network that anyone in the world can
join by downloading the bitcoin software
think of it like a voting system where
each computer on the network
costs a vote to determine the legitimacy
of the transaction
after a certain number of transactions
are made a new ledger is created that
links back to the previous ledger
and so on and so forth which is what
we've come to know as blockchain
technology
you see the real question isn't about
the intrinsic value that bitcoin
provides to the world
look at the us dollar what gives it
value take a second
think about it in fact what gives any
currency
value the dollar itself has no intrinsic
value it's just a piece of paper or a
number on a screen
what makes the us dollar valuable is the
fact that the government decrees
it has value and we agree that it does
we trust that our dollars or pounds can
be used to purchase goods or services
because the recipient of our money also
trusts in its value
in other words the value of a currency
comes from people's trust in the
currency
and the underlying stability of the
state that is backing and
issuing that currency the difference
here however is that whilst
fiat currency relies on the stability of
the government
bitcoin using its blockchain technology
relies on
computer code for a currency to be
valuable it's important that the network
of people using it
trust in it bitcoin has been playing a
psychological game of trust and
reputation
since its genesis a tug of war between
good press
bad press and the overall adoption of it
from other users
if there is demand then it has value
bitcoin has clearly
generated that demand the question we
should be asking then
is not about its value but rather its
demand
what's fueling it and more importantly
can it last
make no mistake the game of trust and
reputation is not
easy and until bitcoin gains mass
adoption
it is walking a tightrope between trust
and fear
and behind the scenes there are bigger
and more concerning problems at play
ones that threaten to snap the tightrope
bitcoin walks on
there has been a civil war within the
bitcoin community
for some time now behind all the memes
hype and laser eyes
one which questions bitcoin's legitimacy
as a currency
it's known as the block size war and it
comes
not from an external threat but from an
internal one a problem that has been
built
into the very foundations of bitcoin
itself
the great problem of scalability satoshi
nakamoto
programmed it so that each block on the
bitcoin blockchain can hold
only up to one megabyte worth of
transactions
and to make things trickier there is a
set difficulty level on the bitcoin
blockchain
ensuring that it takes 10 minutes to
generate every
new block with this single decision
nakamoto had unintentionally
lit the flames for conflict let's run
some quick numbers
an average transaction size is about 380
bytes
therefore every block on the blockchain
contains roughly 2759
transactions and if every block takes 10
minutes to generate
it means bitcoin can guarantee only 4.6
transactions per second visa on the
other hand can handle over 24
000 transactions per second you see the
problem
nakamoto's design decision caused a
split in the community
a split between the big blockers and the
small blockers
big blockers argued that any legitimate
currency needs to handle a lot of
transactions
far more than just 4.6 a second they
advocated for
increasing the block size limit
meanwhile the small blockers
argued that increasing the block size
limit would mean that the average person
would not be able to run the bitcoin
network due to its sheer size and scale
causing it to be run by bigger
corporations and therefore become
centrally owned something that bitcoin
was designed to oppose
but that's not all because we haven't
even talked about the energy problem yet
on the 12th of may elon musk put out a
tweet explaining why tesla
that it once allowed their vehicles to
be purchased using bitcoin was no longer
doing so
stating we are concerned about rapidly
increasing use of fossil fuels for
bitcoin mining and transactions
this was a tweet that single-handedly
sent bitcoin tumbling down in worth from
the high fifty thousands
to the high forty thousands remember
it's a game of reputation
and trust and musk isn't the only one
who's expressed the lack of trust in
bitcoin's energy use
the energy problem has been around for a
very long
time in fact a recent analysis from
cambridge university indicated that
bitcoin uses more energy
than argentina it uses a lot of energy
the whole issue
around energy remarkable just how much
energy is involved in industry that
consumes a lot of energy
the question you're probably wondering
is why why does bitcoin
use up so much energy and yet again the
problem is that satoshi
had designed it to be this way every
computer on the bitcoin network is
casting a vote to say whether the
transactions on a block are valid or not
but how do we ensure that someone isn't
able to simply cast as many votes as
they possibly can
and effectively rig the system this is
where nakamoto
outlined their proof of work system
computers on the bitcoin network would
have to prove the work that they've done
to cast their vote and the way that they
prove this is by solving a complex
numerical problem that essentially
forces
a computer on the network to consume
energy in order to
solve it the first computer on the
network to solve this numerical problem
claims the reward of a few bitcoins for
having successfully validated that block
in other words it's like a lottery a
bunch of miners attempting to solve this
complex numerical problem
consuming energy in the process in the
hopes of being the first to claim their
bitcoins
as a reward nakamoto had made it so that
each block must take 10 minutes to
generate
meaning that the numerical problem will
adjust in difficulty
so that it will take roughly 10 minutes
to solve every time so the more
computers on the network the more
complicated the numerical problem will
be
in order to keep the block generation
time at 10 minutes
and the more complicated the problem the
more energy and power is required to
actually solve it it is a vicious
cycle it used to be that a regular
computer could be used to mine bitcoin
during its early days
but now there are entire mining farms
created with extremely powerful
computers
in order to continue mining bitcoin the
proof-of-work model was a clever way of
preventing bad actors from rigging the
bitcoin network but it was
highly inefficient when it came to
energy usage and scalability and with
climate change and global warming it
places a big
ethical burden on bitcoin and its future
or does it
many in the bitcoin community snapped
back at musk's decision
calling these accusations propaganda
designed to plant fear
uncertainty and doubt into the minds of
others comparisons of bitcoin's energy
use to that of entire countries
is unfair and disingenuous bitcoin isn't
trying to be
a country it's trying to be a currency
or a store of value
bitcoin miners are also incentivized to
use renewable energies as they get
cheaper to produce
think about it as a miner you want to
make money since energy costs are your
biggest expense
you're going to want to find ways of
generating energy as inexpensively as
possible as renewable energies like
hydropower become more affordable you'll
find that miners will gravitate towards
it but it's incredibly difficult to
predict
just how much energy the bitcoin network
is using is renewable energy
some analyses predict the network to be
using over 70
renewables whilst others say it's less
than 30 percent
and whilst our banking institutions and
monetary system consumes more energy
than bitcoin they are dealing with far
more transactions and users but just
when you think
bitcoin has faced enough issues there is
an even
larger conspiracy looming in the
background
in 2019 a paper published by a professor
and a student at the university of texas
titled is bitcoin
really untethered accused bitcoin's
price of being manipulated by another
cryptocurrency one
by the name of tether tether is what is
known as a stable coin
it's a cryptocurrency that is pegged to
the value of the us dollar in other
words
one us dollar is worth one tether coin
no more no less converting a bitcoin
into a stable coin is much quicker than
trying to convert bitcoin into u.s
dollars
and so many bitcoin holders will attempt
to move their money away from bitcoin
into tether
when the markets become too volatile and
according to a study by crypto compare
57 of all bitcoin trading was done
in tether tether is a huge source for
liquidity in the cryptocurrency market
however the 2019 paper suggested that
there had been
unbacked creation of tether coins which
were then swapped for bitcoin to
artificially drive up demand
this paper became a huge deal in the
cryptocurrency space
launching an investigation by the u.s
justice department into tether limited
and bitfenix the two companies behind
the actual coin and there is this
phenomenon of tither
and every other day there's a billion
dollar of it issued that goes to buying
bitcoin
the investigation found that the virtual
currency tether
was not at all times backed by the us
dollar as previously believed which
resulted in an 18.5
million dollar fine tether is still
around today with a promise of more
transparency but it underpins a darker
issue
surrounding bitcoin the issue of market
manipulation
see there's something else i haven't
told you about there are these things
called
whales not those kind of whales
bitcoin whales individuals who own large
sums of bitcoin
according to coindesk the number of
wallet addresses holding over 1 000
bitcoin in january was 2
30 satoshi nakamoto themselves is said
to own roughly 1 million bitcoins from
their early days of mining the currency
that's more than 4.7 of the total supply
of bitcoin there will ever be
so let me pose a new question what would
happen if satoshi nakamoto
would sell their coins it's unlikely
that they whoever they are
would but it emphasizes a new problem a
bitcoin whale
holds the potential to cause a larger
price movement with their holdings
especially if they were to sell there
are twitter accounts literally dedicated
to analyzing the movements of wallets
holding
large amounts of bitcoin and to make
matters worse bitcoin's decentralization
and anonymity
makes it a place ripe for individuals
with nefarious intentions who would be
willing to manipulate the market to some
degree
how much of it is being manipulated is
hard to tell
so that's it then bitcoin's scalability
issues it's poor energy efficiency and
potential
to foster large amounts of market
manipulation render it a poor
currency if that was where the story of
bitcoin ended
it would be a bleak one but where
bitcoin's problems arise
is where the world of cryptocurrencies
and something much
bigger begins
[Music]
the year is 2011. it's a time where the
emergence of alternative
cryptocurrencies or
altcoins for short begin to make their
appearance look
a little deeper and you'll see that
blockchain technology
is not exclusive to bitcoin and in the
wake of bitcoin's problems
the development of these altcoins
offered a solution
or the creation of something entirely
new i can't possibly outline every
single one of them because there are
currently
thousands of altcoins out there each
supposedly designed in their own unique
way with a distinct purpose
the cryptocurrency space is a wild west
right now
filled with debates about which coins
are worthless scams and which ones are
revolutionary
dogecoin another alternative
cryptocurrency was literally
invented as a joke by two software
engineers intended to make fun of the
wild speculation in cryptocurrencies
that joke is now at a market cap of 50
billion dollars at the time of recording
that's worth
more than ford is the cryptocurrency
space currently in a massive mania and
bubble
probably but pause for a second let's go
back to the 1990s and early 2000s
tonight the information
super highway and one of its main
thoroughfares an
online network called internet amidst
what we now call the dot-com bubble
this was a time when the internet was
finally being commercialized and there
was a buzz about its potential and what
it meant for the future in all of our
lives
investors began pouring tons of money
into some of these internet companies
giving them ridiculously high valuations
it was a mania with some companies
simply adding.com to their names just to
cash in on the hype some of these
companies had no business plan
no product and no profit and when
capital began to dry up
many of these internet companies that
had no purpose or real business
collapsed
[Music]
but even so years later internet
companies are some of the largest in the
world
i believe that it's very easy to
predict that they're going to be lots of
successful companies
born of the internet i also believe that
today where we sit
it's very hard to predict who those
companies are going to be
it's possible that the crypto space is
in a similar situation
right now in the year 2014 a 19 year old
by the name of vitalik buterin
stood on stage at a bitcoin conference
unveiling their plans for what they
called
the ethereum network vitalik knew the
blockchain technology was something much
bigger
than bitcoin that it had potential far
beyond the world of finance
blockchain technology is to bitcoin what
the email is to the internet just one
part of a bigger picture
and that's what makes ethereum so
interesting the ethereum network
gives us the possibility to actually
program and create
decentralized applications or
decentralized contracts commonly
referred to as
smart contracts now i won't go too much
into the computer science behind it all
because it's
well beyond my comprehension but it is
seriously fascinating and incredible
stuff
and we are only at the start of this
thing everyone gets caught up on bitcoin
because it was one of the first
dominoes to start this all but bitcoin
is a small part of what is a bigger
picture do i personally think that
bitcoin will be the global currency of
the future
no but that isn't to say that it doesn't
have its uses other than being a
currency
when the internet was first getting
started we didn't know that it would
allow us to watch videos online by other
people on a social media platform
it was a process of evolution and
although i have no idea
where this world will go and which
cryptocurrencies and uses of blockchain
will last
into the future it is exciting bitcoin
isn't a
scam or a fad it's much rather
a story and it seems to only have just
begun what about this internet thing you
know anything about that stop
giving me that pop-up ad for
classmates.com
nothing with crypto in the title ever
turns out good
a digital artwork sold nearly 70
million dollars it's tied to the
ethereum blockchain
i don't care that your phone takes
pictures it's a phone
because the whole thing is a joke
using it for things like financial
contracts digital assets all this sort
of standard stuff
it's easy to criticize something you
don't fully understand and i still don't
get it and neither do you
or anyone else behind the bitcoin the
technology itself really
very powerful
[Music]
hello my friends and thank you for
watching to the end of the video
if you haven't already seen it this is
part of a two-part series so do feel
free to go and check out part one should
be linked
somewhere at the top here but if you
liked the video do hit the like button
do hit the subscribe button i promise to
bless your feed with
only good content if you're interested
in knowing a bit more about the behind
the scenes how i edit some of the
effects if you
are interested in having q and a's with
me and whatnot i do that all on my
patreon it's pretty cool the link for
that will be in the description below so
do check it out if that is something
that interests you i look forward to
seeing all in the future projects to
come there's a lot of exciting ideas
that i've got as always my friends
hunter head salute
you